le premier ministre jacques chirac
tenait un meeting ce soir à strasbourg
c'est là devant la foule de ses
supporters qu'il a appris officiellement
la nouvelle de la libération des otages
regardez écoutez plutôt on doit
respecter ses droits comme on doit
respecter le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes
je je voudrais vous annoncer que je
viens à l'instant je viens à l'instant
d'être je viens à l'instant d'être
informés que les trois otages français
que les trois otages français retenus au
liban viennent d'être remis entre les
mains du représentant du ministre de
l'intérieur
et donc ce soir au cours d'un meeting de
la campagne présidentielle à strasbourg
on l'a appris tout à l'heure le chef de
l'état françois me